we might have to stop calling each other
hos and for a while does anyone
have that girlfriend hey hooker I
actually think we need to steal from
what guys do with their nicknames cuz
guys build each other up with their
nicknames all right what up champ what
up chief what a boss guys give each
other promotions in their nicknames
I make television shows I have an intern
he's 20 years old people walk in they
like what a boss and like what no I'm
your boss
I'm your boss that's nobody's boss
that's my friend's nephew who was too
stupid to get a job so I had to give him
an internship because he got a two on
his SATs
so that's nobody's boss best-case
scenario he will be a hooker so let's
just get this I'm your boss
I don't like any of the nicknames my
girlfriend's give me they'll be like hey
honey hey cupcake I'm like what are you
doing you don't like it when guys call
you that
let's just all stop calling women
desserts for a while if you must call a
woman a dessert at least pick like a
cool dessert you know like bear claw
what a bear claw